so let's talk about this shifted
structures what what do you find works
what should be done each of you has set
up multiple programs and and and you
know what do we need to do to enhance
this well I'd like to think what we need
to do the hands this is NYC service but
yeah but i will say seriously we i think
and you know the city thinks that we
think we have a city full of people that
have something to offer i think what was
so wonderful about eric statements was
it really was this this belief that all
of us have something to offer all of us
have this ability in this capacity to
serve and so we think the structure that
needs to be in places we live in a time
where people are used to being serviced
and so we've got to make it simple as
simple as possible for people to connect
to service opportunities how do we do
that what sorts of things this is like
an NYC service commercial yeah we would
say you set up 39 initiatives no um but
what we do think that there is a role
for a coordination between government
efforts higher education efforts
philanthropic efforts it really needs to
be thoughtful and it needs to meet
people where they are we would say we
need to understand that different people
lead different lives they have different
capacities we we call it your blank
people have different blanks to give and
then back to another point that we've
been making we would also say that
service has got to there is something
inherent and service that is about
personal interaction and it's about the
one on one that being said the service
industry has got to meet the world where
we are so for instance I just rolled out
a facebook application if you come to
NYC gov / service you can plug in your
interest and your zip code and we will
periodically send you opportunities that
are in your air
in your interest interesting and so we
do think there has to be this move to
work service being more of a actually a
kind of service industry and helping
people to make that connection and use
what they have so I'll get an email
that'll say if you're interested there
can be some tutoring at this elementary
school nearby you absolutely yeah and
you how do you find the response to this
so far um we've been oppressed I think
people are impressed with our numbers
but you know you may have heard my boss
is a bit of a taskmaster so I would say
he's moderately impressed he just got
reelected yeah yeah Tuesday was job
security day so but the but I think we
have been impressed but we are not
finished I think in a city this size the
numbers are are pretty interesting I
think we have a website that has
someplace between thirty and forty
thousand unique visitors a month that
sounds big but that's not large in this
city and but that also begs a question I
we don't necessarily think that everyone
involved in service needs to come to our
website Colombia has a huge push for
service we know there are tons of people
serving that will never hit my website
but someone is meeting people where they
are and provide any opportunity some
entity is making that happen and really
using service to address strategic
challenges